this work is literally explaining the
way the human brain functions to keep a
human being alive and so if you need to
go the science route it's there for you
if you need to go more of the spiritual
route it's there for you but in the end
the only thing matters is how do you
feel today and if the answer is not
great in whatever way shape or form then
this is your life
isn't it worth just replacing your fear
and your anger with curiosity
[Music]
welcome to episode 110 of the michaela
peterson podcast this episode is with
nicole sacks
nicole sacks is a speaker writer
podcaster and psychotherapist who has
dedicated her work and her practice to
the treatment of chronic pain
she's a faculty instructor at the omega
institute the art of living retreat
center and author of the meaning of
truth embrace your truth create your
life i wanted to speak to nicole because
my family has been through a lot in the
last five years in particular and i've
been learning what i can to help them
quick update on that things are much
better now and these podcasts the next
four of them i believe were recorded
when things were really really really
not good so if you guys are worrying
about us
we're good i think the petersons are
back in the game finally for the first
time in maybe three years
i had someone reach out and tell me that
nicole had really helped her with
chronic fatigue and fibromyalgia so this
episode is about trying to treat that
kind of thing psychologically i hope you
enjoy
[Music]
nicole sacks welcome to my podcast thank
you happy to be here
i'm excited to talk to you i was
referred to you by
somebody on instagram who said you were
the go-to person
for
trauma stuck in the body and how to
relieve that
so i thought that would be fascinating
to get into
could we just start off by you giving a
brief background about who you are and
what you do
sure so um my name is nicole sacks i am
originally a psychotherapist that's how
i sort of started this whole journey
because i was in private practice for
many years i no longer am
but actually if we're going to be really
honest i started this journey as a
patient of chronic pain
because when i was 19 i was diagnosed
with a condition called degenerative
spondylolisthesis which is a severe
abnormality of the lower spine
and that was delivered when i was 19
after my let's say my back went out
that's the most easy way to describe it
when i was a freshman in college and so
i was carded home and i was subjected to
all the tests and this this was this
severe abnormality was found which is
that they gave me a pretty dark
diagnosis um no travel no sports um very
strict sleeping positions no more than
one hour in a bouncy car
pretty much for the rest of my life at
19 so that was kind of harsh and of
course the biggest one was the
likelihood that i would have a
biological child was slim to none
because the weight of the baby on the
front would put up put so much stress on
my lower back that it could send me into
the kind of incident that would be um
irreparable and i could end up in a
wheelchair so this was the prognosis at
19.
oh my god i had no idea that's
terrifying oh yeah i mean it's it
defines your life at that point and um
so
essentially you know i i look at this
when i when i pan out and i look at the
big lens obviously this was all part of
my journey and what was meant to bring
me to where i am today which from what i
know about you michaela is similar i
think you know we all use our personal
journey as part of
the um the steps on the path you know to
where we're going and so that's where it
began um and uh i will really make the
story short which is i traveled through
my life with a great deal of fear and
trepidation but also with an
understanding that just just out there a
little bit that life was bigger than
this and i didn't quite know how it was
going to turn out but it wasn't going to
be as simple as what they were
um
prescribing uh to be my life and as i
moved through my experience i came into
um the world of mind-body medicine and
understanding about brain science and
about the nervous system about what it
does to the body to be in sustained
fight or flight and what that does to
the different systems of the body and um
the my primary mentor and teacher was dr
john sarno
i don't know if you've heard of his work
but he was the he was the pioneer of of
what i teach he was an attending
physician
at the rusk center for rehabilitation at
nyu medical center for 50 years he
passed away at the age of 94 a few years
ago and so he was the pioneer he wrote
he kind of wrote the original theory
that
i took and evolved into what i do today
and he was also originally my doctor
then he became my colleague then he
started referring into my practice and
so it's it's a great um
source of pride that i was directly
connected to him before his death so i
could have that one-on-one interaction
with this genius man and then bring his
theories to the fore and so through
doing the work and through understanding
the brain science and understanding that
i was not broken that actually we all
look different on the outside and we all
actually look different on the inside
too and just because i do have the same
severe spinal abnormality if you take my
mri today you will see it it never
degenerated i had three biological
children and exercise till the day they
were born i travel the world i play
sports i exercise i'm
more fit maybe than i've ever been i'm
49 and i just
live a completely unencumbered life
because i understand this stuff so
essentially i was in private practice
for years and my patients were like you
can't confine this to the
you know the four walls of your office
it it not it they really encouraged me
it was them who encouraged me and so
that's when i first wrote the book
um i wrote my my first book in 2012 i
rewrote the whole thing in 2016 because
i had learned so much more and that's
when i started sort of traveling the
world and teaching and running retreats
and writing online courses and so that's
kind of where i'm at right now trying to
bring this message to the global
community because
every time i reach another person and
have them tell me their story
and michaela the stories are really dark
i mean as i know you know from yourself
and your father chronic illness can
bring you to the darkest places possible
yeah and um
i and i will tell you that it is a
regular occurrence that i will hear from
somebody from australia from
africa from india from south america
someone i've never met that says i was
contemplating my suicide i was on my
couch at three in the morning on a deep
dive and google because i
nobody could tell me what was wrong with
me or they could tell me all these
diagnoses but no one could fix anything
and i was in such severe pain or anxiety
or panic that i was planning my suicide
i kind of tripped over your work in this
sort of
crazy coincidence whatever you want to
call it and i've been doing it for six
months and i'm thrilled to report i'm
back to work full-time i'm getting
married i'm having a baby like these
crazy stories and so i just i'm just
incredibly passionate not only for my
own body and my own world which is my my
life is my message but also just for the
way it helps people to bring this
message far and wide
okay
that was a great intro
so how do you
what is your work how do you do the work
to get out of that kind of chronic pain
okay so first of all i want to make sure
to define chronic pain correctly because
chronic pain is not just back pain neck
pain shoulder pain migraines
fibromyalgia
although it is it does all these things
it's also chronic fatigue it's also
anxiety in all its forms panic in all
its forms irritable bowel disease and
stomach problems in all their forms many
skin disorders and then it can be as
gentle if you will as a lack of joy for
life and exhaustion um an inability to
see just the lightness through the
clouds it's basically
the way every single person is in the
world you know there's no cure for the
human condition but when i say chronic
pain when i first started my brand i had
to pick something so i picked the cure
for chronic pain because i needed to
find a place to start but it's just so
much bigger than that so i always feel
the need on the front end to define that
correctly because i want the umbrella to
be big enough to fit anyone underneath
it that that qualifies which is kind of
every human being even if it's just like
i said a lack of joy for life we all
deserve the whole buffet not the scraps
under the table so okay
so having said that there are three
facets of my work so you say what is the
work um believe
do the work and patience and kindness
for yourself
so
i really think all three of those facets
are equally important so um and i'll
explain them briefly so believe is
essentially
we're talking about brain science so
your nervous system will protect you
without your permission and without
asking your opinion
so your belief that something can help
you your perception of being helpable if
you will
is your reality
um and i'll give an example i tell this
story sometimes i was in london i think
it was like a while at 15 years ago
let's say and i was in the midst of the
city downtown wasn't paying attention
looked the way i would assume a bus
would be coming um and stepped into the
street to cross the street being a new
yorker i don't follow traffic rules very
well i'm sort of you know
a little bit brash that way and um so i
just
started to walk
by the time the double-decker bus
whizzed past my face so i could almost
feel i felt the air in my face and i
literally almost felt like it could
brush past my nose i was already back on
the curb with no memory with no memory
and no intention of jumping back there
it is amazing what your brain and your
nervous system will do for you when the
perception of danger is detected
obviously before i had any place to have
an opinion or give permission my brain
went into action it jumped my body back
on the curb i a million percent would
have been dead it flew past me so fast
and so close
and i always use that example to just
kind of hammer home
the intensity of this process and the
reflexivity of this process this is an
automatic process when we are being
protected
so when i say believe
there and and i'd say the law the
largest part of my work the biggest body
of my work is to help people believe
which is why my podcast is focused so
much on success stories and on
interviews and on real-time heels which
is something i do where i do a cold
therapy session with someone i've never
met and they tell me their story and i
literally in real time
work with them so people can see how
this works and i do all this stuff on
the regular so that's available to
anyone who's interested
i spend so much time helping people
believe because our fear and our
resistance to this process is part of
the nervous system protecting us because
the brain and the nervous system
perceive
our stored trauma and our repressed
emotional world as a greater predator
than our physical pain conditions or
state of being
that makes sense
right so like let's say for example you
have
capital t trauma let's just take it to
the best the biggest extent capital t
trauma abuse neglect um being raised in
a wartime situation anything that is
extremely traumatic
the memories of that and the reliving of
that are perceived by your nervous
system as much more dangerous than a
migraine or fibromyalgia or anything
that makes you stay small and quiet and
lay down and stay away from the world so
it will keep you there in a quite loving
and protective way
until we can
make our systems aware
that it's safe to feel these things and
of course it's not always safe
but there's work to be done which is in
the second facet of do the work there's
work to be done to convince this system
that protects us without our permission
that that we can feel that we can be
with our experiences once that happens
and this is why the work can be rather
miraculous if you deign to use that word
the nervous system is like a switch when
you flit flip from fight or flight to
rest and repair systems go into
equilibrium remarkably quickly because
in many ways we are incredibly similar
to the animal world so if you look at
like a um a herd of gazelle they'll be
grazing they'll be at the watering hole
the predator is introduced the lion
walks onto the savannah the whole herd
goes up the ears go up they start
communicating with each other everyone
is tense they're ready to flee and let's
say it just casually keeps walking maybe
it just fed or whatever as soon as it's
out of energetic range
the whole herd usually shakes it off
they go back to grazing they don't run
50 miles just in case it comes back
that's not the way our animal brain
works and that's the part of us that is
protecting us even in our evolved human
state and so
once we flip that switch once we allow
the brain and the nervous system to
understand that this stuff we've
experienced is experienced although
traumatic although incredibly painful
is safe to feel and to be with and that
we can do that
the pain signals stop firing this is why
people have these incredible
transformations you know i have clients
regularly who are in motorized
wheelchairs or are bed bound for more
than a year like really long time that
are now running marathons i mean i'm not
joking this stuff is insane in terms of
the transformations so i don't want to
keep going if you have questions but
that's the belief
yeah go ahead i do um how do you
convince somebody who's been in
chronic
fight or flight or chronic pain for
years
that
they can calm down
because that's kind of what you're
saying right yeah you're asking an
excellent question just like throwing me
these uh these softballs because you
can't
you can't because it's the nervous
system and it's the same thing that's
took me off the curb in london that's
why we do the second thing which is we
do the work
because no one can calm your nervous
system down but you i can talk you into
belief
or i can talk you into suspension of
disbelief
i can bring you to a place where you're
open
but nobody can do the work for you which
is another really unfortunate part of
this that people can feel really angry
about
because it's way
i often say my work is simple but it's
not easy meaning what i'm about to
explain to you today michaela is not
going to blow your mind and it's simple
it is pretty simple but the reason it's
not easy is because it takes consistent
patient work with ourselves to bring the
nervous system which has the mentality
of let's say an abused child or an
abused animal like a dog
that is ready for for attack or for
flight or for fawning or for fro being
frozen it's ready it's at the ready so
the way you convince
oneself or a person
is by doing the work and so what the
work is um
i teach a practice called journal speak
now journal speak is indeed a journaling
practice but it's not just a journaling
practice it's essentially teaching you a
foreign language it's teaching you to be
fluent in a second language and the way
that works is that i teach people to go
to the places that are
very triggering
gently and softly by doing it at the
pace of their own consciousness
and so
essentially here's the way it works
you make three lists
one is labeled childhood which could
also be labeled past stressors one is
labeled daily life which is anything
that is a the constant onslaught of what
we're dealing with today which often
times there are bridges between the two
and the third is personality because a
lot of people that are the highest
for lack of a better word highest strung
um most susceptible to this kind of um
dance between the brain and the nervous
system are people who are
perfectionistic who are goodest meaning
it's very important to be seen as a good
person to be helpful people who are
rather codependent meaning like enmeshed
like i'm not really okay unless you're
okay
people who are their own worst critic um
you know people might tell you you're
okay but if you find some problems with
yourself that's to consume you and this
energy of this kind of personality and
there's many other traits um can really
feed it's the lens through which every
experience is filtered you know because
we are who we are and so we make three
bulleted lists and they don't have to be
um really they don't have to expose you
in any way it's like names of people or
um big categories like money or like for
me i moved a lot as a child like
constantly and so i was always making
yeah and so like moving was like a huge
thing in my childhood that really got me
got me unmoored um
so so the list is exhaustive it's really
just a brain dump to the best of your
ability you can always add to the lists
of everything that could be
just a thing and and people get
especially the personality types um get
very um like i want to do this correctly
so i get a lot of questions about the
list and i'm like no no there's no way
to mess this up
unless you just choose not to do it like
it and the list also could be something
so potentially trivial as like that time
in fourth grade with the bully but that
time in fourth grade with the bully
matters you know and and it affected you
if it affected you and sometimes the
things you think are going to be the
biggest heavy hitters turn out to be
just playing your tapes and just your
stories and sometimes the smallest
things that you think were no big deal
open up an experience that can really be
transformative
so once people make these lists i teach
them this practice called journal speak
which is an impolite
unfettered
rant
allowing of the inner child because i
also do a lot of work around inner child
work allowing to the of the inner child
to scream to scream to cry to be a
victim to to win the argument because
even the best parents even the most
loving parents shut us down as kids it's
the very nature of childhood versus
adulthood and
every so so there's a reservoir inside
of us of rage
shame
sadness grief that has been unfelt
experiences that have not been seen and
heard
um
terror fear meaning there's so much okay
so this reservoir exists inside of us
and what the journal speak process does
is it dips a ladle in this reservoir and
it dumps it off every time you do it and
so
the reason for chronic symptoms is that
when the reservoir i know i'm giving a
lot of information but i'm i'm sorry but
it's like there's so much to this it
works it works okay
just interrupt me please if i'm if it's
too much um when the reservoir hits
maximum density and threatens to spill
over and inform your conscious brain the
one that the nervous system is always
monitoring for danger
how overwhelmed you are how terrified
you are how unable to manage you are how
triggered into your past trauma you are
when it hits maximum density that's when
a symptom fires because essentially the
symptom fires to protect you
because it is a protective mechanism if
you can feel your fibromyalgia your
migraine your back pain your your
shoulder pain if you can give it meaning
if you can go to the doctor if you can
obsess on it
what was going on over here calms down
you stop thinking about it because you
only have the capacity to think very
seriously about one thing at a time and
so it's a distraction it is a
distraction it is a protective
distraction and it freaking works
because as soon as you are attending to
your health which without our health we
have nothing we all know that and as
soon as you're attending to your health
or your pain which will get your
attention just like this before anything
else
these
mental
tumult this mental tumult over your
unresolved stuff it lays down
it really works i mean if you start
thinking about it in yourself we all can
come to understanding how it really
works
and so
essentially what this journal speak is
doing is gently and systematically for
20-minute sessions at a time followed by
a 10-minute loving kindness meditation
so it's a 30 minute practice
dumps a ladle out
calms us down and through repetition and
practice what ends up happening and i
have 20 years of experience to the most
crazy transformations the stuff over
here the distraction stops happening
it people often say it's magic and i'm
like it's not magic it's brain science
but it it feels like magic when it stops
happening because you can't believe
that just unearthing this stuff and
sitting with it
makes migraines go away it's migraines
are so physical they make you throw up
they make you blind and and another
thing that's kind of amazing about my
ability to teach this is i have gotten
everything
everything i've been treating people for
over 20 years i got it all i had the
migraines i had the fibromyalgia i had
because it would run through me almost
like my body needed to
show me how to teach
it's been amazing and i am a person who
is chronic pain free in across the board
because chronic pain
is an epidemic of fear and meaning
chronic pain isn't about the pain it's
about the fear of the pain it's about
the anticipation of the pain that sends
the nervous system
into this fight or flight leaves it
there and then creates it's it's it's
it's an unfortunate vicious cycle
and uh and i'll just throw it in there
so then we can open it up for questions
the patience and kindness which is the
third aspect is just so integral because
we are not kind to ourselves we are not
self-compassionate we beat the [ __ ] out
of ourselves at every turn that's what
we do and that continues to dump in the
reservoir and it keeps the system going
and so i do a lot of work on inner child
work and on self compassion not hippie
dippy self love i'm talking real solid
i am here with you as if you would be
with a friend
that's that's the overview
five years ago i would not have believed
any of that
at all
but
after i stopped taking medication so
ssri's specifically
and started ex because that really
put a kind of a wall up or numbing on
all of my emotions which i didn't
realize until afterwards but when i
started experiencing these
emotions properly i realized that if i
didn't experience them if i just kind of
shut them down that it would cause pain
right and i was like that's amazing so
if you you know if you're in a horrible
situation
and you don't cry
you don't experience grief you know my
arms hurt i get like yeah spots on my
arms that feel like somebody's pushing
on them yes it's like oh that's what
that was you know it's a little bit odd
to have an autoimmune disorder and then
to also have emotional things impact you
physically and i guess it's more obvious
if you think about a rat in a cage
that's being stressed yes they're going
to physically show that right they're
going to lose hair and things it's going
to physically impact them but
i wouldn't have believed it five years
ago especially not for something as
serious as
you know fibromyalgia or chronic pain
well i completely empathize with that
there are i mean what to me is the most
um
amazing expansive part of the human
experience is there are tons of things
that you could i that you could say i
wouldn't have believed six months ago i
would have believed
six days ago you know i i'm just gonna
throw it in here just because it's
timely one of my very very dear friends
died um in the miami building collapse
this week oh my god and it has been so
sorry thank you and it's been absolutely
consuming me but
because i'm so
in tune with my mind body system and the
way it moves through me i'm literally
feeling
how my grief and how my anger and how my
shock
is moving through my body and it's it's
like
i i
it's it's it's an experience that i had
not had and i could have explained it i
could have speculated on it a week and a
half ago but today i feel it differently
so what's amazing to me is the way we
evolve constantly and if we're just open
if we're just open to underst to
understanding that that we don't know
everything
if we are just open to that that's for
sure it can be
a much more um
educational experience being alive and
so i i empathize that you didn't
understand this five years ago or you
wouldn't have been open to it but that's
what's amazing about this human journey
is like if we can just stay willing
it keeps informing us
okay so then i'm gonna ask this this is
kind of the same thing i already asked
but
my mom is
my mom had cancer and she she's in
remission and
whatever she tapped into when she
thought she was going to die has really
helped her
express express emotions i'm going to
just stumble through this express
emotions and try and
like let go of almost what she couldn't
control and
um she did that partly through aa partly
through religion but whatever she's done
has completely changed how she reacts to
fear and stress and and all those things
this episode is brought to you by
grass-fed beef organs
by ancestral supplements ancestral
supplements makes new zealand-sourced
nose-to-tail organ meats bone marrow and
beef organs in simple convenient gelatin
capsules traditional peoples native
americans and early ancestral healers
believed that eating the organs from a
healthy animal would strengthen and
support the health of the corresponding
organ of the individual for instance the
traditional way of treating a person
with a weak heart was to feed the person
the heart of a healthy animal similarly
eating the kidneys of a healthy animal
was believed to support urinary ailments
and overall kidney health pancreas was
fed to people with digestive problems
and spleen was fed to people with immune
and blood deficiencies
our early ancestors knew this which is
why their traditional diets included the
frequent and nourishing consumption of
nose-to-tail organs visit
ancestralsupplements.com
to see what they can do for you
ancestral supplements putting back in
what the modern world has left out i
hope you enjoy the rest of this episode
how
would you start a conversation with
somebody who you think
could be helped by this but
isn't there like isn't ready to believe
that is there
something you can do that can maybe open
them up
it's an interesting question because it
gets into spirituality and it gets into
readiness what is true readiness um but
i'm going to answer it anyway my my
initial knee-jerk reaction is people
become ready and when they become ready
that's when they open and when they open
that's when things can come in like your
experience of feeling pain on your arms
alleviate when you felt your feelings
opened you to something that you could
never have been convinced of
and so
that that's my my knee-jerk reaction but
i but i think i feel like i can i can
answer that a little bit better
which is
my contention is that desperation leads
to surrender and surrender leads to
openness and truth
and so what i do for people
um let's say friends right so people are
who are not hiring me um professionally
that are just people i love dearly who i
watch suffer
i stay close not too close
i stay
open
i become i hold space for their anger or
their you know
people love to kind of give me the side
eye and go like oh i'm getting the back
surgery and i go then that's what you're
gonna do you know like so what for it's
kind of like what's the sound of one
hand clapping like i don't push back
i just
stay really
centered in what i know so i'm not going
to say what i believe michaela i'm going
to say what i know and when i can stay
centered in what i know and hold space
for people to get desperate enough to
surrender
that's what i do
[ __ ] okay
i do you know what i thought it was
gonna be i thought it was gonna be
something like that because i was
thinking back to when i was like sick
and really
stressed and suffering and
there wasn't anything anybody ever said
to me that suddenly switched something
on it was all like pain and suffering
and then
slow realization more openness you know
what you said so that's too bad because
it can be frustrating seeing people but
i want to say i agree with you in it
trust me there's no one more frustrating
to me especially with my freaking
children okay so i have a 13 year old an
almost 17 year old an almost 19 year old
and these kids are living a human life
so they'll be stressed and they'll have
like things like stomach things or like
you know my daughter's a dancer and
she'll get like foot pain and oh my foot
you know and all i want to do is be like
let's feel your feelings and they just
want to be like screw you so i yeah yeah
there's
trust me i empathize with that so
tremendously but here's another thing i
want to say because i always bring it
back to the brain science because it's
the capital t truth yeah
we don't have a choice but to listen to
our fear-based nervous system until
there's a second option
so people that you see in that level of
resistance
are
it's like i have such compassion for
them because they're in option one and
there's only option one for them because
they have not yet seen another option
but someone like your mother brought to
the brink of her mortality got open to a
second option and so it's like i almost
feel like energetically because even if
you're not a spiritual person you must
believe in energy it's it's the theories
of relativity it's einstein it's energy
theory it's quantum physics it's true
that we are all just energy and
everything in this society and in this
world and in the human experience is an
energy exchange and so what i do when
i'm with a person like that is i i just
center i do a lot of meditation as well
it's just a personal practice and i
center myself in my compassion for their
predicament because they don't have a
choice when they are in option one which
is the nervous system is locked into
protecting them which is an ideological
as well as a physical experience
do you know what i'm saying like your
mind will be closed if your nervous
system thinks that feeling this stuff or
opening yourself to this stuff is too
damn dangerous
so that becomes an ideological paralysis
that i can just sit in compassion
for that person and i do watch people
open all the time
okay
i'm gonna try
tr try to get around this in a way you
can tell me if this just wouldn't work
but are there like is there any type of
scientific paper that you could send to
somebody who
at least believes fully in that
type of information and then that could
trigger their openness it's a great
question i mean it's i'm not a scientist
i'm not a medical doctor so my
credentials are i'm a psychotherapist
i'm a licensed clinical social worker
i've been done other um foundational
training um trauma informed that kind of
stuff but that's the extent of my
experience having said that
dr sarno's colleagues and the greater
medical world are doing studies all the
time and this body of work is growing
and i'm on an international list serve
where people are posting their papers
so so yes
and it's not going to make a freaking
difference like i i can't tell you how
often i i could bring so i once had a
meeting with one of the top um doctors
at mount sinai in new york and he
said he could get me in front of grand
rounds and he was really open he was
really a cool guy he he just was able to
see the big picture
and i i
created an annotated bibliography
of all these different studies that are
really
statistically significant studies
um
and they rejected me they wouldn't let
me come to ground rounds
so um
i just i i i
stand in belief that the world is
changing
that the pandemic helped us with this
that just
consciousness
and just the evolution of human thought
helps us with this that it will keep i
will be invited more and more it's just
we're we're in a space of change and
flux and i have to be patient
well i hope you're right
okay
so so some more
some more questions then okay um so i
i've learned how and i think i'm this
might be wrong but i think i have an
easier time releasing emotion now
as a female than a male at least that's
what i've seen from and talked about
with
like males around me about this kind of
emotional release so i've seen
men around me get really stressed out
about something and then they don't seem
to have a switch like i have built where
i can feel it cry a bunch
and then feel that relief
and it doesn't feel appropriate for me
to be like
maybe you need to have a cry because
they're like i can't
right so are there things you use
more specifically for men to allow them
to feel that type of emotion yeah you
know i think that you're what you're
saying is absolutely right on that um
culturally we have created norms we
haven't created them we're just born
into them that um
make certain feelings and certain
emotive processes safer for a woman than
for a man or people who identify as
female versus male and um
so
once again it's sort of similar to how
how can you convince someone question
yeah it all comes down to each person
making hard choices so oftentimes i say
about this work this will never be a
top-down communication process of
healing meaning you're never going to
turn on your tv and have the big pharma
commercials talk about don't take this
pill feel your feelings you know you're
not going to go to your orthopedic
surgery consult and have them say hey
listen back pain doesn't actually make
pain go and back surgery doesn't make
back pain go away which by the way
a lot largely and widely it doesn't um
they won't say that they're not going to
be saying that to you so this is a
bottom up healing approach which really
means each person him or herself has to
decide the answer to the most important
question in the world which is
how long would you like to suffer
and i can be standing in front of a hall
before kovid in front of a hall of a
thousand people and i'm having this talk
and i could look i look i look at all i
get the eyes of as many people as i can
and i go
that's the question you how long would
you like to suffer and it's not supposed
to be a question that insults people
it's supposed to be a question that
empowers people because as soon as you
decide in your own personal set setting
in here
no more
no freaking more okay with that kind of
intensity like with what you can feel in
my energy right now no enough
if you decide that
you can transcend
male and female barriers of feeling you
can transcend your resistance and your
disbelief it must come from
understanding that life is a choice
between what hurts and what hurts worse
there's no third option and it can be
applied to the most banal stupid thing
like do i want to eat this sugary snack
i want to eat this sugary snack here's
how i usually feel after i eat it
um but it's delicious okay so here we
are in a situation of what hurts versus
what hurts worse and i would say on any
given day
i'll eat it or i won't depending on
where i am but it's but there's no third
option there's no third option of eating
the sugary thing and feeling great
because i know myself and that's not how
it's gonna go so it's either eat it
because it's more delicious to eat it
and it's worth it to me or not and and
that so that's a small and like that
goes all the way on the other side
spectrum of like do i have a child or
not
right like do i have a child or not
do i want to forego my own needs from
now until the day i die you know like or
can i live without having this child
like when i thought about being a mom
it was so cle and i know you're a mom
well it was so clear to me
i
will be suffering in pain worse if i
don't have these children i know they're
gonna steal my soul and they're gonna
wreck me with their suffering and
they're going to like take away all my
personal autonomy i knew that i was i
was old enough to get it but
i i wanted them
and so
when you can align yourself with the
truth
that life is a choice between what hurts
and what hurts worse and when you can
stop
begging and pleading the universe for a
third option where you can do what you
want and have no suffering attached to
it that's when we get peace that's when
we can live in the presence of our
experience okay
you get it yeah i do i do kind of get
that and
what i learned over the last well i
don't know i guess 29 years
realistically but was that whole thing
the the emotions i had which was like
you know when i was
little and i was diagnosed i was
confused i was angry that diagnosed with
arthritis right and then there was a lot
of confusion a lot of anger and a lot of
fear
through the medical system
and
i i remember deciding in grade three
that i just wasn't going to cry anymore
it was like i'm not like i don't want to
feel that it's weak but mostly i don't
want to feel that right and that screwed
me over for a really long time and i've
only recently realized that
feeling it even though it makes
everything worse for a little bit
because expressing that emotion hurts
the relief that comes after it
is so worth expressing it and it seems
like that seems obvious and it seems
simple like now that i've
understood that but
you know getting angry or getting sad or
feeling grief i think grief is a really
big one feeling grief for when things
don't go right or when you see somebody
else suffer
feeling that and it kind of lets it go
for some weird reason which is amazing
really that you can be sad and then
express it and then not be as sad
what i want you to understand michaela
is the moment before you figured that
out it hurt worse to cry
and that's the that's the thing that's
true
and that's what people need to get and
that's why i i do everything i can to
release the shame
connected to not healing fast enough or
five years ago or to not you know doing
things differently until you did things
differently because the truth of the
matter is it works both ways
in third grade where you decided you're
never going to cry again that was the
less painful option until it wasn't
anymore and what's really amazing if we
if we're aware okay so if we keep
ourselves awake and aware of our eyes
open when those scales tip just enough
that we can understand that staying
where we are hurts more than the
uncertainty and the fear of stepping out
when we're aware of that then we move
and i think the most painful time
actually the most painful time is when
the scales have shifted but we're not
yet aware so we're just suffering in the
in the current choices in our present
situation not understanding why does it
hurt so badly until and maybe it could
be in the form of listening to this
podcast for one of your listeners like
until something and it could be it could
be the breeze that blows past your face
like there's it's so random something
wakes you up and your eyes open and you
go wait a second
hurts worse what i'm doing that's why
that's why it's so hard right now and
that's why some people
experience what they call an extinction
burst which is when they start doing
this work the pain actually gets worse
they start they start um poking the
hornet's nest of their trauma and of
their repressed emotional world and
they're like
they're tempted to quit because like
their pain is getting worse or their
pain's moving around so like fine my
migraines went away but my anxiety is
crippling and i say yay
i'm all about that because that means
you have it on the run and that means
you are beginning this process of
healing so it's so important to be
really gentle with yourself as you're
going through it
okay so speaking of being gentle with
yourself
how do you
teach people how to be kind to
themselves you have tricks for how to be
kinder to yourself or the meditations
you use or something
yes the first thing i want to say is
okay so the first important thing to
understand is it is important to be kind
to yourself
for years and years it never occurred to
me that that was important i mean i i am
i i am a
real reformed like what you're seeing
today is not the person i'm a fly not
the person that um
that you would have seen when i was 25.
i was a go-go-go
outcome-dependent
i want the a
everything requires i i don't want
anyone to help me i can do it all myself
yeah um for like years and years and
years probably a great deal of my
chronic pain was a result of that so um
so i didn't if you had told me so see
you say five years ago you wouldn't have
believed what i'm saying if you had told
me in my 20s let's say that
self-compassion was important i would
have told you to [ __ ] off like i would
have just been like that's the dumbest
that is first of all it's for weak
people second of all exactly yes second
of all it's a waste of time third of all
it's like just not me like you know how
we all say that's just not me okay so
what i think the most important thing
first is for people to know this is a
real thing self-compassion is concrete
if you don't have it you are suffering
it's like it's like being thirsty and
not having water like i i think i think
people need to understand that if you
don't feed this part of yourself this
this part of your um emotional
consciousness i could say this part of
your heart but that's even too soft it's
it's a part of your of the emotional
energy that surrounds you if you don't
feed that you will be
irritable you will be defensive you'll
be reactive you will be you'll push
people away these are concrete things
that you don't want to do they make your
relationship suck they make your life
less full and so when sometimes the best
thing i can do is is give that list and
be like have you been feeling that way
and most people be like um yeah and i'm
saying okay then first thing you need to
know is self-compassion is the real deal
and it's not just what for people who
you know want to live on a commune like
this is a very real thing
um so that's first thing
second thing is you know cultivating
best practices like i'm not an expert in
self-compassion and i can't reinvent
every wheel so i look to the experts
like dr kristen neff neff she is
a world-renowned researcher in
self-compassion and she has practices
that i teach you know crediting her i
teach them at my retreats because
it's just using you know it's using the
tools that have been invented
but but explaining them properly to
people with the right context in order
to
open them to make everything is a
practice everything is a practice so
it's like if you wanted six pack abs you
could go to a trainer and they could be
like this is what you do you do this you
do this and you do this and you could be
like that's very interesting if you
don't do it it doesn't matter
so like it's it's a it's it's a practice
okay
that makes sense
neff chris okay i'm gonna remember yeah
and if you're interested i mean i don't
want to go go on and on if you have more
questions but if you're interested i can
explain to you a little bit about
kristin's work but i would i would yeah
i bet
okay so essentially the the um kind of
the gold nugget of it is
so we are very very good as a society in
practicing compassion other compassion
yeah so what what what um generally we
do in my retreats when we work on this
stuff is we first cultivate what it
would feel like bring ourselves into the
space of your your best friend or your
child or your dog or something you feel
very warmly to toward is suffering
how would you behave what kind of body
language would you use what kind of
words would you use what kind of tone of
voice would you use so we kind of come
into that space and then
we say i say
now i want you to picture the last time
you really screwed something up you
really disappointed you missed the mark
you really like you messed up what was
the tone of voice what was the
body language that you used toward
yourself what were the word choices that
used to yourself so we start to first of
all delineate between other compassion
and self-compassion and or lack of
self-compassion and we do some exercises
around um the physical feeling like
holding fists and feeling the energy of
that and putting arms out and closing
eyes and feeling the energy of that and
just understanding the difference
delineating between this feeling of
self-loathing and self-criticizing
and self-compassion
and then it kind of culminates in what
we call a self-compassion break
which is
bringing into your consciousness a
problem that you're having okay so it's
not not super big trauma like um for me
like i'll just give an example it could
be um
getting my daughter ready for camp
and dealing with the fact that she had
real anxiety about camp and then covet
happened and then um so now i'm worried
that she's gonna struggle
and now there's all these coveted
regulations on camp so it's like it's an
irritating problem that gets me
emotionally kind of up there but it's
not like a horrible life-ending problem
so you bring yourself into the energy of
that and then you do what's called a
self-compassion break which is you
repeat three phrases the first is simply
it's all labeling this hand to heart
this is a moment of suffering
that's it okay isn't it amazing though
like you feel that energy shift just
acknowledging ah
this is a moment of suffering i'm still
i'm still at the stage where just
hearing that makes me feel like snorting
which isn't
like which means i'm which probably
means i'm just not there and i'll be
there in like three months but that kind
of you know this is a moment of
suffering i don't know how i could take
myself seriously and do something like
that even though i fully believe you
fully i just
okay but that's so amazing in three
months no but that's amazing michaela
because here we are in the midst of a
conscious
moment of conflict like you're you're
conscious enough to know that you
probably will shift on this oh 100
but that's so you're not you're not
stuck in kind of the thickness of that
moment where like you're just like okay
nicole whatever move on that stupid
right so like you're conscious enough to
have an observational self look i'm
being a therapist right now but you're
confident enough to have conscious
enough to have an observational self to
say hmm that's so interesting i'm
observing that this is making me
skeptical or this is making me roll my
in my inner eyes okay yeah but what's
incredible
is i would um
invite you to try it maybe later
get yourself into the space of something
that's really bothering you you know
your kid isn't going through what my kid
is but your kid's going through
something or your dad's going through
something or somebody in your life is
going through something that matters to
you and it makes you suffer and if you
can bring this is why the in the
retreats this is a really powerful
exercise because people are each in
their own little bubble of experience
and when you
sit there in your discomfort and label
it and say this is a moment of suffering
okay you can take the hand off your
heart if that's too cheesy for you like
labeling it
being present with it so like the way
you would if someone else were suffering
and like you wanted to ign you wanted to
see them you wanted to make them feel
seen and heard like you're not alone in
this essentially this is a moment of
suffering we need to say that to
ourselves because when we're suffering
we feel so alone
even if other people are suffering
around us our own personal hell feels
very alone and so the the um
self-compassion break the first sentence
in that which is this is a moment of
suffering is an acknowledgement is a
seeing
of like how we wish others might see us
or how we would be willing to see others
to acknowledge
this sucks for you right now it's hard
for you okay so maybe that can be a
little bit more palatable
yeah you know what something clicked
while you were saying that i actually
i i sit with it now like i know enough
that when i'm feeling the grief or or
compassion or stress or something when
somebody else is suffering
i'm aware enough to say you know what i
this feels horrible right now
but it'll if i experience it it'll go
away so it's not uh this is a moment of
suffering which is what i said what me
what made me slightly skeptical but i i
don't think i've been naming it i think
i've just been experiencing it and being
like it's okay to experience this but i
haven't said this is what it is
so that's not very far apart no you're
you're not gonna take three months you
might take three more minutes you're
almost there okay okay okay you're so
close um so so that's the first sentence
which is this is a moment of suffering
the second
sentence is essentially
everybody suffers
right it's just about taking this human
experience that you're having and making
it ubiquitous
suffering happens for every person you
know there's a line that i think is
really powerful which is never compare
your insides to other people's outsides
you know like we're so used to like
looking at other people and being like
they've got it all especially in the
world of social media and comparison and
what do they say um compare and despair
you know and so like
if you don't if you can that second
sentence once you label your moment of
suffering to say
everyone suffers everyone is going
through what they're going through in
their own way and opening yourself up to
like basically being a member of the
human race
and then the third sentence is just in
this moment very simply what can i do
right now to be kind to myself
and it can be as simple as
i'm pausing the stupid you know social
media or whatever on that's making me
feel terrible
i'm going to take a walk i'm going
outside i'm putting the sun on my face
for one minute whatever it is it breaks
the cycle of that constant
self-criticism or self-loathing or
whatever negative ugliness you're
feeling
and if you do that enough that's it
cultivates self-compassion it's sort of
a concrete way to cultivate
self-compassion
okay so those are just steps people
could use to start being answered to
themselves yeah and also just to touch
into the moment because it's not just
being nicer to yourself it's to
feel like in sort of a cellular way how
to shift out of it because if you know
human beings are very unconscious beings
if we don't concretely shift out of
things we stay in them so it's just it's
a practice
okay that makes sense
let's see i had a whole bunch of
questions for you okay okay you you talk
a bit about chronic fatigue syndrome so
that's something i suffered from
terribly
and then i managed to
change my diet and get off of medication
and
probably start experiencing things and
it went away thank goodness but
for people suffering from chronic
fatigue syndrome is it the same kind of
steps that you talked about before
trying to like ladle out unfelt emotions
yes so this can be a really triggering
conversation just i'm gonna tell you
that straight up because first of all
chronic fatigue is incredibly
challenging really it's really it's it's
a bad one and i'm not saying that to
make anyone frightened if that's what
it's it's no harder to recover from than
anything else but the experience of it
is incredibly deflating because without
any energy to do anything
it feels impossible to take necessary
steps which is what we're trying to tell
people to do so i just want to bring
connection to that chronic fatigue is a
really really tough one
having said that the other reason it's
triggering and this could be applied to
chronic fatigue or any diagnosis
is that people get very
tied and um
connected
to their diagnosis because they have no
other choice so once again i want to say
this with complete empathy and love
because i've had almost everything has
moved through me so i get it
that um including chronic fatigue
that
what i'm about to say is the truth which
is
your chronic fatigue is his back pain
his back pain is her pelvic pain her
pelvic pain is his migraines his
migraines is her irritable bowel disease
it is immaterial the way this process
shows up in one's body
so that can be triggering for people
because people are like i am a person
with migraines i have a migraine
disorder this has ruined my life don't
tell me that i'm not a person with
migraines and i'm always saying this is
not what i'm saying what i'm saying is
the manifestation of the brain science
that causes the nervous system into
fight or flight that causes these
symptoms to fire
is it's it's just immaterial the way it
shows up in people so although chronic
fatigue is a certainly a thing
it's treated no differently than
migraines or back pain or knee pain and
i just know that people really get very
up in arms about this but it's just the
truth and the reason i know it's the
truth
and this is where you can either choose
to believe me or not and that's on your
you know that's on your path whatever
i've been doing this for 20 years over
20 years now in my own body and with
thousands and thousands of people around
the world and i watch what happens which
is they present with chronic fatigue
they start doing the work the chronic
fatigue lifts and they call me and
they're like i have having these chronic
daily headaches i can't get rid of them
and i say i know honey i love you it's
okay let's keep going and then they
continue doing the work and they're
unearthing more things and they're
becoming more intimate with their trauma
and maybe they're making some changes in
their lives maybe and not always but
like it happens and then they're like
it's the damnedest thing the headaches
are gone i haven't had a headache in two
weeks my anxiety is so high and i say i
know
because this is what happens it's that
like until the nervous system which i
said has the mentality and the emotional
ability to understand as a five-year-old
child who's been abused because it's a
it's a primitive system
we have to just stay with it
consistently and kindly until and and
eventually all these things that move
through you which by the way this
doesn't happen to everyone but
eventually
it passes
and then you become a person who simply
is a human living a human life i'll get
a headache it's not like i never
experience pain it's just that i don't
experience fear with it so when i have a
bad headache i don't think i'm always
going to have a bad headache i think
today was a lot
and this is going on and this is going
on and there are things going on that i
can't even possibly know what's going on
and i practice acceptance sometimes i
take too advil like i'm not like
completely
against the medical model whatever you
know do whatever you do
and then like i allow it to pass
i feel what i need to feel i'll jump to
my journal speak practice i'll talk to
my therapist i'll
i'll go to a meeting it could whatever
and then it passes so it's really so the
answer to your question is
it's really all the same stuff
okay
why would
it manifest so differently in people
this is where we have to open to the
mystery of the human brain
so um you know there's a cliche and i
don't know what percentage we're up to
in 2021 that you we only the best
scientists in the world only understand
six percent of the brain and i don't
know what percentage we're up to but
it's not high absolutely not six yeah
it's it's somewhere but i have no idea
okay
so
the way i can explain this best is think
about the phenomenon of adrenaline so if
a
baby is trapped under a car
a parent in that moment will have the
capacity to lift the car it's been
documented scientifically many times
it's an adrenaline response it is a it
is a short period of superhuman strength
that is enacted by a
flood of cortisol and adrenaline based
on real panic and need to preserve life
that allows the brain to allow the body
to lift a car and you and i both know we
could go outside right now with all our
best intentions and there's no freaking
way you're going to lift a car
so this is truth okay what i'm saying is
truth
in that same fashion
the brain and the nervous system can
perceive in each person the place in
your body and in your system that it
will be believed
that it will be enacted upon
now sometimes i believe this has to do
with the structural abnormality i do
have did i have spondylolisthesis
my mri is jacked like if you show my mri
to an orthopedic surgeon who doesn't
know about my work they go pale they
don't know what to say to me it looks
really gross i've seen it i have i have
a vertebrae that's shattered and
replaced with scar tissue
i have two vertebrae that sit on top of
one another without a disc
i have stress fractures above and below
i look mutated it doesn't affect me at
all except for a couple
physiological connections to
spondy which is that i have almost no
flexibility in like i can't touch my
toes i can get down to like mid calf
because it's just it's just a structural
um and it's very hard for me to sit up
straight like when i meditate i need to
sit up against a wall or something
because it's i have weakness i i have
like it's very mild but except for those
two things
which are just structural i have no pain
ever ever ever
and so what i'm saying is the pain
i believe
i had a childhood it was not horrifying
but i had a very stressful
death by a thousand paper cuts kind of
childhood
um that needed to be expressed that by
19 had reached critical mass and this is
where
my you know the buck stopped with this
with this place in my back and then when
i went for the mri of course it was
totally reasonable that this would be
the reason for my pain and off we go
not everyone gets a finding there's
really no finding with migraines or
fibromyalgia or irritable bowel usually
you know there's it's so it's so it's
it's it's it's just
this is where we have to
just kind of release ourselves to the
mystery because i don't know why it goes
some people seem to find a reasonable
place you know that that story i told
you is reasonable sometimes there isn't
okay
well that's very interesting
i've like
through trying to
heal me and through my family being sick
i've there's just so many
factors that come into play and they all
seem to matter which is crazy right at
the beginning i pretty much put myself
into remission with diet and was like
diet is
everything right because that's what
changed my life
and then
you know
my family members got sick and i started
suffering again
and i was like well i seem to be more
sensitive to food how is that possible
you know like like oh there's more to it
than this so then i was like oh sleep
matters
wow that was mind-blowing and it was
like oh exercise actually does improve
your life right and when you're
cripplingly depressed when someone tells
you to go on a treadmill and you're like
[ __ ] you that's not gonna help and it
was like oh exercise matters and now
it's like
oh you're
you know your experience of emotions
can make you sick which is crazy and i
think i i learned a lot about that when
my mom had
cancer and
through all the scientific studies we
looked at it was like she's going to die
and that's what everybody said
and then she had surgery which also
almost killed her and then she
even though it wasn't supposed to work
she like found god
became okay with something
something switched and you could see how
she interacted with people and it was
like and she was she knew when she was
going to get better and then she got
better
it made no sense and so
i don't know man well no i actually want
to say something about this i don't know
how you're going to feel about it but
i'm gonna say it anyway
i'm not saying
that diet wasn't important and i'm not
saying that sleep isn't important and
i'm not saying
i'm i don't discount any of it and i
care about my diet and i care about my
sleep but in my opinion
all of those things are simply vehicles
to move your nervous system from fight
or flight to rest and repair
all of them
so if you believe
diet now diet does matter so i'm not
discounting it but if you believe diet
works and you do the diet and it works
because it's also part of the diet
the only thing that matters to your
brain and your nervous system when it
comes to creating physical illness or
exhaustion is safety
if you believe you are safe just like
the herd of of gazelle
once safety is registered through the
system
there is no reason for the system to be
inflamed and once inflammation is
reduced which is very quick once we are
in a space of safety
everything goes
and it falls into place
and so that's why i believe it was like
one thing for you and then it was
another because all of these are
vehicles toward the ultimate source of
human health which is the state of the
brain and the nervous system and if we
feel like we can operate in optimal
physical health and if you study the
brain science of what happens when a
person is in sustained fight or flight
digestion shuts down okay yeah
the first thing that happens is
digestion shuts down why because when
you're running for your life you
shouldn't be hungry or have to go to the
bathroom you know like it just makes
tons of sense you know um circulation
and respiration go up that's why we feel
anxious that's why we feel like we can't
get a deep breath because our body is
trying to help us
fight flee
freeze or survive in other fashions and
so when that necessity when that
necessity is eliminated by whatever
means we're doing it that's when we
start feeling free and healthy
okay that makes sense to me
that makes sense to me i hopefully this
podcast can
help people i think you have to be at a
certain
at least i had to be at a certain level
of
openness even to consider emotions had
anything to do with my well-being which
seems silly looking back on it but i was
very
science-oriented and
if there wasn't hard evidence in a
scientific peer-reviewed paper then it
wasn't true
and now i have no idea what's true
anymore
which is the best place to be but here's
here's what i want to say here's what i
want to say to people out there who
might be listening to this with like
super rolling eyes and like continuing
to like
turn it off but then not and like being
tempted to get rid of us okay so i'm
speaking to you
speaking to you who wishes they would
turn it off but they can't
um
this is your life
this is your
precious
life
if you believe in reincarnation if you
believe in whatever that's great but
this is your life that you get to be the
specific you with your children and your
loved ones and your job and your
self-esteem and your beautiful moments
okay this is yours
what's it worth to you
is it worth opening your mind just a
little bit
because although
science is what you said you needed this
work that i'm discussing with you is
more scientific than surgery
this work is literally explaining the
way the human brain functions to keep a
human being alive and so if you need to
go the science route it's there for you
if you need to go more of the spiritual
route it's there for you but in the end
the only thing matters is how do you
feel today and if the answer is not
great in whatever way shape or form then
this is your life
isn't it worth just replacing your fear
and your anger with curiosity replacing
your resistance to something with just
saying i wonder
because once you do that your body
becomes your proof
just exactly what you've been saying
this whole podcast michaela the reason
you're a believer is your body has been
your proof once we once we live a lived
experience of something it's very hard
to unlive that and so that's the way i
get people to heal i say just give me a
month
i tell people to take the 28 day
challenge of doing my work and i say
note how you feel today
and there's a video on my youtube
channel called the 28 day challenge i
say note how you feel today this is what
you do every day for 28 days note how
you feel at the end and decide if this
is a worthwhile practice for you that's
worth it even a skeptical person could
give it a month-long shot yeah
okay
on that note
if people want to find out more about
this or want to follow you online where
the where should they go
so um okay i have a podcast which um
airs every friday called the cure for
chronic pain with nicole sacks lcsw
tons and tons it's like i think i've
been doing it for two or three years and
i've never missed a week so just tons of
free information there with like case
studies and scientific you know
conversations with doctors and real time
heals which is this therapy i do like
right there with people i don't have
never met before and so like it's really
like kind of
awesome to be in the in the room with
that so there's that um there's my brand
is the cure for chronic pain so i have a
youtube channel called the cure for
chronic pain i have an instagram where i
put out new stuff every day which is
where you found me
at nicole sacks lcsw
i teach retreats so um depending on when
this airs i will be at the omega
institute for august 1st through the 6th
and that will be something where we have
five days with myself and just this
dream team of instructors that it really
really changes your life i must say it's
a real transformative experience to be
at a live retreat so there's that um i
have two online courses it's called
one's called freedom from chronic pain
one's called freedom from an anxious
life i do a lot of work to get
information available to people much of
it is free so that they can just begin
this for themselves and then if they
need more help they can take a course i
have a facebook community called
journals fake journal speak with nicole
sacks that is a closed group so not
nobody sees what you post except the
members of the group and it's thousands
of people in conversation about this
stuff supporting one another asking
questions answering questions
um
just google my name i'm all over the
place
okay thank you very much for coming on
and talking to me that was really
interesting thanks for having me that'll
help it was really great
[Music]
you